Дніпро міліє, замулюється та зеленіє дедалі більше.
У ньому розмножуються синьо-зелені водорості.
Спека пришвидшує ріст бактерій і водоростей, коли вони мають
прогріту територію, швидше і в більшій кількості розмножуються.
А водну поверхню і дно захоплюють інші водяні бур’яни.
Це водний горіх. Він так цвіте, що закриває всю водну поверхню,
і ультрафіолет не проходить, не збагачується киснем вода.  Риби тут застрягають.
Риба в Дніпрі гине все частіше.
Кияни з подивом знаходять у воді вже навіть медуз.
З’являються вони тому, що в Дніпрі змінилася екосистема,
Дніпро перестав бути річкою з великою течією,
русло змінилося, побільшало водоростей, які забирають кисень.
Вода стає все більше токсичною і для людей.
У спеку особливо. На усіх міських пляжах Києва
вже вивішені червоні прапори небезпеки.
Температура води у Дніпрі +26. Купання заборонено.
Такі прапорці, каже рятувальниця з п’ятирічним стажем Ольга Клиновська,
вивішуються вже не перший рік. І з кожним роком дедалі частіше.
Вода не відповідає нормам купання. Ми маємо ситуацію перед очима.
Вода цвіте, вода має відповідний запах та колір.
Стан води в Дніпрі цього літа можна порівняти зі станом хворої людини,
у якої температура за 40 і в організмі починають виходити з ладу
системи життєзабезпечення. За даними комунального підприємства "Плесо",
яке слідкує за станом води, спека стала додатковою причиною розмноження
щонайменше небезпечної для людини кишкової палички.
У деяких місцях фіксують перевищення в 5-10 разів.
Проте киян це не зупиняє.
Ха- ха! Кишкова паличка!
Я не купаюся.
Усі ми помремо колись.
Ми купаємося, але не пірнаємо.
Ми просто не пірнаємо, щоб нічого не підхопити.
Ми ходимо в душ. Антисептиком руки обробляємо
після води, щоб нічого не підхопити.
Не чистять річку. Ще є викиди із заводів,
добрива вони роблять, потім усе цвіте.
Реальний стан води в Дніпрі показали результати дворічного скринінгу
річного басейну. Це безпрецедентне дослідження на більше, ніж 2000 різних
шкідливих елементів було зроблено урядом за допомогою Євросоюзу.
Найбільші забруднювачі річки - сільськогосподарські отрутохімікати,
важкі метали, фосфати, фармацевтичні відходи, зокрема ліки,
якими лікували хворих на коронавірус, також парфуми - ті, що в засобах
для душу, пральних порошках, побутовій хімії тощо.
Досить труїти Дніпро! Пора творити добро!
Київводоканал нам не бро!
Ековолонтер Богдан Ференс заснував рух проти забруднення Дніпра.
Активісти вимагають від влади Києва, комунальних підприємств чистої води
в Дніпрі  і  моніторять всі колектори, через які Київводоканал
скидає неочищені стоки. Також інші комунікації, куди в Дніпро
йде без очистки вода після дощів зі сміттям.
Ось як може виглядати те, що витікає з колекторів. Волонтер радіє, що хоча б не постійно.
Ми знаходимся на славнозвісному колекторі, який
є одним з головних забруднювачів. Він близько до пляжів, 800 метрів - 1 км.
І це є надзвичайно небезпечно. Що з цим робити? Топ-забруднювачі
мають нести відповідальність і мають бути покарані  за це забруднення.
Коли температура води перевищує 25, то купаючись навіть на відстані від колектора
насамперед слід боятися не інфекцій, каже ековолонтер,
а банально хімічного отруєння чи навіть хімічних опіків,
ступінь яких залежить від того, що саме скидають.
На думку ековолонтера, реального контролю за тим, що скидають у Дніпро, у Києві немає.
Мало хто знає, що в ці колектори часто врізаються садиби приватні.
Тобто тут були виявлені врізки.
Промислові підприємства, автомийки, баркасні всі ресторани…
Все це є серйозною загрозою для стану водних ресурсів.
Держекоінспекція звітує в середньому про 300 порушень законодавства
щодо водокористування щомісячно. Останні три роки виписуються рекордні штрафи
на сотні мільйонів гривень. Але не всі вони сплачуються.
Багато цих справ "розвалюються" в суді.
Ексголова Держеконіспекції Єгор Фірсов розповідає, що успішних кейсів
рятування тих же річок від забруднювачів, яких суди змушують
зробити модернізацію очисних, один-два - не більше.
Ти можеш виписати  штраф тощо, приходиш до суду, і в суді
інспектор з зарплатнею в 12000 грв, з купою завдань різних,
ще під тиском, стоїть один перед п’ятьма людьми в краватках Бріоні,
які отримують по кілька тисяч або й кілька десятків тисяч доларів.
Плюс корумповані суди. Як правило,
виграє бізнес.
Екологічні активісти час від часу критикують дії Держекоінспекції,
закидають екоінспекторам бездіяльність або відсутність дієвої реакції на забруднення Дніпра.
Як каже ексголова інспекції Фірсов, законодавство не дозволяє інспекторам
зробити позапланову перевірку на підприємствах - їх банально не впустять.
Але і з цим можна боротися.
Якщо це системна політика і підприємство знає, що порушило,
якщо скинуло наднормово в річку, і воно отримало мільйоні штрафи,
і це системно, це змушує до модернізації.
Тому ця політика має бути системною хоча б декілька років,
щоб якось це змінило звичку. Так, Держекоінспекція - це суттєвий інструмент.
Вона може впливати.
Теперішній голова Держекоінспекції говорить про те, що наразі налагоджена
співпраця з окремо створеним відділом Генпрокуратури, і результати розгляду
екологічних порушень поліпшуються.
Також інспекція очікує прийняття законопроєктів, які наразі на розгляді,
про посилення фінансової відповідальності підприємств за забруднення річок,
про суттєве збільшення штрафів - 300 000 грн за відмову надати доступ
на підприємства інспекторам. У цьому році до правоохоронців передали 112 справ,
відкрили лише 14 кримінальних проваджень.
У шести випадках суди винесли рішення про припинення діяльності забруднювачів.
Поки, визнає Андрій Мальований, майже не вдається вплинути на діяльність
водоканалів, які і є одними з головних забруднювачів Дніпра.
По кожному водоканалу: Миколаївський, Білоцерківський,
Київський - після кожної перевірки встановлюються порушення.
Перевищення та порушення є. Що потрібно робити?
Треба фінансувати реконструкцію майже всіх водоканалів, застарілі станції очистки.
В маленьких населених пунктах чи середніх взагалі очисних немає.
Фактично, стоки майже не очищені, недоочищені скидаються у водні артерії.
Держекоінспекція чекає на затвердження державної програми з реконструкції
очисних споруд. Зокрема у того ж Київводоканалу є шанс на модернізацію
згідно з угодою між Україною і Францією, яка надає кредит на це
в розмірі 70 млн євро на 40 років. Такий шанс вже 10 років є і у станції аерації в Бортничах.
Це єдиний очищувач каналізаційних вод у Києві, на це кредитні гроші
виділило японське агентство міжнародного співробітництва.
Проєкт поки не реалізований.
Водоканали підпорядковуються муніципалітетам, міським радам,
територіальним громадам. Тому завдання цих органів - не просто заробляти,
а інвестувати в реконструкцію очисних споруд,
в будівництво нових систем очистки стічних вод.
Якщо дуже оперативно не змінювати ситуацію на краще,
то це дійсно може призвести до катастрофи.
Спека пришвидшує процес отруєння Дніпра.
Враховуючи те, що з цієї ріки споживають воду до 80% населення України,
проблема вже виходить на рівень загрози національної безпеки.
Відсутність питної води - не така вже й далека перспектива,
б'ють на сполох і в Держекоінспекції, і екоактивісти. Члени київського "Екопарку Осокорки"
наголошують на тому, що рятувати Дніпро треба разом з усією його системою
маленьких річок та озер, які є природними біофільтрами дніпровської води
і які поступово знищуються через забудову.
Коли десь відбувається забудова на узбережжі річки, чи винищення плавнів,
засипання болота - все це в результаті має вплив на Дніпро.
Тому що вода з Дніпра потрапляє в дрібні водойми навесні.
І далі відбувається очистка цієї води на біля узбережжя
біофільтрами, водоростями. У нас є вибір або зберігати Дніпро і його мілини,
усі прилеглі біосистеми, або ми можемо все це забудувати-забетонувати,
а потім бідкатися, чому ж така вода зелена.
Активісти вітають рішення уряду про поступове обмеження використання
фосфатів, які сприяють розмноженню синьо-зелених водоростей у річках.
Проте кажуть, що це лише часткове вирішення проблеми цвітіння води в спеку
і нагадують про те, що узбережжя Дніпра, русло та заплави активно забудовуються
за рішеннями міської влади, яка має навпаки бути зацікавленою в порятунку Дніпра.
КМДА вживає багато заходів для порятунку Дніпра,
запевняють у комунальному підприємстві "Плесо".
Підприємство встановило на міських озерах системи зрошення
для збільшення кисню в воді, вони працюють ввечері, і їх всього три.
Є і ось такі сучасні машини, які скошують водяні бур’яни.
У "Плесо" вважають, що це допомагає: там де регулярно працюють очисні машини і фонтани,
водоростей немає. У комунальному підприємстві хотіли би мати більше такої техніки.
Але фундаментально, вважають тут, треба терміново проводити розчистку
русла Дніпра. Цього не було жодного разу з 1990-их років.
Наразі  в басейній раді, в КМДА і "Плесо"
проговорюється проєкт щодо загального розчищення русла Дніпра.
Це пришвидшить водотік. Бо якщо  замулюється течіями,
міляки з’являються, на них розмножують водорості, вони заносяться сміттям,
і течія зменшується в декілька десятків разів. Якщо течія
поверхневих вод буде швидшою, то воно буде промиватися. І буде чисто.
Погіршення стану води в Дніпрі цього літа може стати найближчим часом
предметом обговорення в РНБО. Екоактивісти сподіваються,
що точка неповернення для екосисмеми Дніпра ще не пройдена.
Опитані DW активісти закликають громади міст
активно включатися в екорухи і впливати на місцеву владу.